[Music]
good evening everyone we have some
incredible stories for you tonight the
capital is in an absolute frothy panic
after senator Al Franken was charged by
a radio host with sexual assault a
charge he has since partially admitted
to it went down like this it was during
a 2006 USO tour in Afghanistan it was
good that Franken was actually doing
those tours but Leon Sweden remembers
that Franken then a comedian forcing a
really gross French kiss on her
backstage he just put his hand on the
back of my head and he mashed his face
again so it happened so fast and he just
matches his lips against my face and he
stuck his tongue in my mouth now this is
how Franken himself recalled that very
tour but he recalled it on the Senate
floor in 2010 we did a four hour show
because we found out that the troops
loved the show I was kind of a co-host
with a beautiful woman named Leanne
tweetIn and we do comedy routines and
we'd introduce music and it just hit the
cheerleaders I go out and do it
monologue he says um a lot as well on
the flight home from that USO tour
Franken groped that beautiful woman when
he placed his hands on Miss sweden's
chest and posed for this photo check it
out
now tweet and posted the picture and her
story online today saying that she felt
disgusted and violated Franken responded
with this statement I certainly don't
remember the rehearsal for this get in
the same way but I send my sincerest
apologies to Leanne as to the photo it
was clearly intended to be funny but
wasn't he did a longer statement later
on in the day and this is the same
senator by the way that just yesterday
was grilling a circuit court nominee Don
Willett about a 2014 20 cent does this
display
the kind of judgment that we want for a
lifetime appointment to the federal
judiciary a tweet was a kind of off
kilter attempt at levity that missed the
bull's eye I don't get it I don't her
enough and but sometimes when you don't
get a joke it's because it wasn't a joke
hmm never have truer words been said by
Al Franken well no one was really
getting Al Franken's joke today at all
it wasn't funny it was really juvenile
it was something you'd see like a drunk
fraternity party maybe or maybe it was
too immature for a fraternity party and
other women still assume may be coming
forward like one of my guests tonight
I'm joined now by Melanie Morgan of
media equalizer she's here exclusively
to share her claims about how Al Franken
stalked and harassed her after a joint
TV appearance and we're also joined by
Brian Maloney also of the media
equalizer duo who's been investigating
Franken's past for us both of you it's
good to see you tonight Melanie I want
to start with you are you are you really
surprised by this story by miss tweeting
tonight she still by the way likes and
respects Al Franken I should add that
but given your own experience are you
surprised then tell us what your
experience was I'm not surprised at all
Loren first of all I just like to say
that I'm here with you tonight without a
lawyer wearing a red coat with a box of
Kleenex in a bucket of Tears I am here
because a true story that I want to
share with you it is a story of
harassment and intimidation that took
place 17 years ago in 2000 August 19th
of 2000 is when I was invited to appear
on the Bill Maher show politically
incorrect before it moved over to HBO is
at ABC and I was one of the panelists
one of the guests I was the token
conservative and Al Franken was the
liberal along with a lieutenant former
lieutenant governor of Colorado and
actor Billy Baldwin I was involved in
just a kind of a really a mundane
argument over policy no
about you know the budget numbers and
making some sort of point about that but
I'll tell you what Al Franken got right
in my face and he just kept coming back
over the top and I would challenge him
about those numbers and he would come
back over the top
finally the show was over and Laura he
trailed me stalked me back really to the
green room where he got my face again
got very aggressive with me I felt
physically intimidated and then he
followed me out of the studio and I
thought this story would end there but
it did not apparently he got my phone
number from the show one of the show
producers and they started calling me at
home and harassing me about trying to
prove to me how right he was
and finally on the third phone call I
told him if he didn't back off that I
was going to call the police and make a
police report about his behavior I found
it so creepy and so disturbing and
obsessively weird and it's an experience
that has informed me about him all these
years I never could understand why the
people of Minnesota elected him as a
United States Senator and yes I did talk
about it in live on the radio on my talk
show in San Francisco the league Rogers
and Melanie Morgan show after it
happened so I didn't stay silent about
it but it's funny Laura because people
don't really they didn't seem to really
care about that sort of behavior until
just recently
yeah well Melanie I'm really glad you
told the story I've had I've had some
run-ins without Frankin over the years
and he's so insignificant to me like I
remember he was sputtering me so angry
was like spitting at me and he was
arguing with me it might have been on
politically incorrect as well but he
there's an underlying nastiness oh
there's there's a picture of Tucker
myself Al Franken and Eric Alterman that
was like in the early 2000s at a New
York Times event but look I've on the
end right I did not want to go near Al
Franken because we got into a really big
bad argument so I stayed away from him
in that particular photo know things I
didn't want it Brian I want to go to you
because you've been documenting and
doing some investigative work today
looking back at some of the things that
he's done and said that it's kind of it
makes us not all that surprised that
this is where we are tonight well really
I don't know where to begin I've been
writing about out Frank
for over a decade and I was going back
through Somalia my old stories today and
I couldn't believe it but there were so
many warnings that the Democrats really
why they ever put him forward as a
candidate that they didn't heed and
really it was amazing because ten years
ago I wrote that they would be sorry for
bringing him forward as a Senate
candidate and it was weird to read that
today and see all that come true because
essentially you know but they built him
up that media built him up the political
class built him up with fluffy coverage
so he never had to worry about being
scrutinized in any way but his actual
background is unbelievable in fact so
much of what he's done hasn't even been
mentioned today and I want to bring up
one in particular he used to write a
column for Playboy called porn arama
and a lot of what was in that column we
absolutely cannot talk about here on fox
news tonight trust me on that
but mm-hmm what I will say I'll try to
make this a PG version or whatever he
talked about his own twelve-year-old son
doing a report for school on bestiality
and how he downloaded visual aids from
his computer to show to the class and
how amused the students were by this so
that's an example of what was in that
column then he made a very disgusting
obscene column mentioned about his some
of his fantasies that he had about what
he wanted women to do and I will not go
any further into it than that but it was
damning right there Bryan Bryan what
you're pointing to the depravity of the
comedy we've talked about this with
louis c.k and the most disgusting images
and that he conjures up in his mind and
passes it off his humor which defines
the man of who the man is and it doesn't
surprise me with Franken either this is
what Casey hunt of MSNBC said today when
they were discussing this issue let's
listen he fought it took a picture which
his office now says was a joke that
showed him potentially not actually
groping but mock groping her she also
published a picture
that was given to her of her asleep with
senator franken mock groping her mock
groping her it's Melanie its mock
groping her so I'm sure if that were a
conservative Senator from let's say
Alabama who had a photo mock groping
someone that's how the MSNBC kids would
describe it correct absolutely Laura you
know people have been talking about this
comparison between Roy Moore and Al
Franken today and everybody's weighing
in on it and here's what I have to say
Roy Moore is a candidate for the United
States Senate and Al Franken is a seated
United States Senator I never understood
I've said this before I didn't
understand why people would elect him
but it was a fair election but now
here's the consequence all these years
later we know who he was we knew then
and now people are getting to see the
rest of the country is getting to see
who he is as well
I think we have Donald Trump just
tweeted about this I'm trying to pull it
up on my phone but it's not coming we'll
put up the full screen so we can read it
the Al Franken Stein ha picture is
really bad speaks a thousand words where
did his hands go in pictures two three
four five and six while she sleeps
so that's the president always always
giving us some humorous a commentary
there this is something that he said in
1995 again we want to paint for the fox
viewers the picture of the whole person
over a course of time not just in this
one incident this is what was said in
New York New York magazine article and
he said and I give the pills to Lesley
Stahl then when Leslie is passed out I
take her to the closet and rape her or
that's why you never see Leslie until
February when she passes out I put her
in various positions and take pictures
of her yes oh so I mean I don't I guess
that's supposed to be funny guys but
again it speaks to the mindset of the
man and I mean I don't know if the
Democrats are gonna do anything about
this I guess some of them came out and
we're
disgusted today but they certainly had a
lot more to say about rowing more that's
for sure Melanie and Brian is great to
have you on tonight thank you so much
for your work on this and Melanie thanks
for sharing your story